now tell people what i do and watson
called an idealist people look at me and
they say so you want to change the world
but actually i don't think that we need
to change the world at all i think that
the world is perfect as it is i think
that what we need to change is help we
treat the world our attitudes towards
the world my name is Li Wei and I live
here when we consider the state of the
world economic collapse climate change
species depletion food crises acts of
genocide terrorism and war and the
increasing disparities between those who
have and those who don't it's daunting
we live in a globalized world where
corporations are getting more and more
influence and have more reach the
government's which are in many cases
bound to their national borders I truly
believe now that enough people can see
through the illusion anyway which banks
can and legally do conjuring to
existence money out of thin air there
are many puzzles and mysteries and the
mechanisms of aging equally puzzling is
why the fight against aging is not in
the world's agenda are just a few people
interested in why we're arranging
critics of aid such as dambisa moyo have
accurately in truthfully pointed out
that we have set billions and billions
of our tax dollars to the developing
world and much of it is just disappear
it's also true that when you are just
dumping money from a rich country to a
poor country you can create dependence
these are problems with eight but it's
also true as people like dr. Jeffrey
Sachs have accurately pointed out
targeting specific problems can create a
huge impact that helped break the cycle
of poverty I believe in non-violence
struggling in fighting against wars in
this world in fighting against human
rights violations three million girls a
year or cut forcibly if GM happens
because women are disempowered they
deserve to reach their potential they
deserve access to education autonomy
over their own bodies we are portrayed
as a world where you have
with ideas with technologies with
capital and the south is portrayed as
the land of lack of opportunity
corruption and problems and if that were
the case then the only thing we need to
do is to transfer money and resources
from the north to south and we know that
is not the pathway that we keep all them
if we want to survive as a species folks
we've got to act together as a species
thank you for your attention well we'd
like to welcome you here my name is
Nicholas Kristof I'm a columnist from
the New York Times and I this is the
unusual session in a couple of ways but
first of all I want to kind of give a
bit of a PG warning and the reason is
that we realized as we walked in that
the topic it says design your cause and
so I think some of you may be here to
figure out how to design your own cause
or or promote it and this emerged
because Julia well ha Maharaj designed
her cause which happened to be female
genital mutilation so as a result this
panel is about a discussion of where we
go and how we deal with female genital
mutilation we didn't want to have a lot
of people wincing in audience if you
were expecting a discussion about you
know how how one goes about designing
your cause so fair warning on and of
course I this is unusual in that respect
that you know we associate Davos with
turgid discussions of interest rates and
Middle East policy in whatever not
particularly about genital cutting the
other way in which this is most unusual
is that this topic arose from a YouTube
audience and we've talked all the time
about the importance of social media how
we can build campaigns well this is an
embodiment of precisely that and if you
are here in the room of course please
turn off your cell phones if you are at
home watching on YouTube then turn on
your cell phones really loudly
and just hit pause as i said this topic
arose because people on youtube were
invited to vote among some competing
ideas i'm competing causes and julia
welcome LOL maharaj when it there's you
want to raise your hand there julia
submitted a video which explains her her
passion her cause and let's cut to that
now last year i volunteered in ethiopia
and one of the things i saw their female
genital mutilation has completely
changed the path of my life I realized I
couldn't look away from this urgent
issue so I came back to London and
volunteered with an organization and a
friend sent me a link to the YouTube
debates saying someone with an urgent
human rights cause had to go to Davos
and i thought this has got to be it so
why send me to Davos because i want to
ask those innovative and intrepid world
leaders to put their hearts and minds
and power behind ending FGM i've just
found out that
since i 1 i've been doing a video diary
every day and really just trying to
raise awareness about the basics of this
very complex issue so what is FGM it's
very simply the removal of a girl's
external genitals the clitoris the labia
and in severe cases the wound that's
left is so not so there's only a tiny
hole left I'm just pleased the days here
actually because there's been a lot of
prep to get to this point it's night one
in Davos and as you can see it's
absolutely beautiful my belief is that
if she's like this can't stay on the
margins that they really have to be
debated at the highest levels
I'll follow up I'm really delighted I
entered this competition who would have
thought ten days later I would go from
my kitchen table to Davos but let's not
be complacent this is just a few days at
Davos there's so much more to be done
there are still three million girls a
year being cut so what can we do
together today to help do something
about this
well the hats off to Julie on that and
fair warning as you can see she may well
buttonhole you in the room and haha and
try to get you to join the movement I
also think it's really quite
extraordinary that considering all the
causes out there that the YouTube
audience a large audience chose this one
as the foremost issue that they wanted
to address and I think in a larger sense
it does reflect the degree to which the
rights of women and girls around the
world are rising on the agenda but Julia
I wonder if you could if we could just
start off by maybe you just addressing
this question of you know given all the
concerns that we have around the world
whether on the human rights for under on
the environmental front economic front
why do you think this one is the one
that should rise to the top and why
indeed did the did the YouTube
generation which is maybe more your
generation than mine alas I sign up for
it you know I think it just really
caught people's hearts and minds and
actually it has languished in that box
that we all tick that says this is too
difficult this is a taboo area this is
something that we didn't know about and
as a result I think just coming out and
saying 3 million girls a year are still
being cut people just caught on to that
and a lot of the comments on YouTube
actually said we didn't realize this
still happened and I think just bringing
it out in that way and also you know
what was wonderful was people could go
very instantly and look Eclipse about
FGM in far more detail so using social
media in that way actually allowing
people to inform themselves about what
the issue was i think you know just
created this this tidal wave of interest
we have a terrific panel and indeed a
lot of questions that have been
submitted by youtube viewers and we'll
also you know invite your comments
and questions as well here on my left
beside me is Kathy Calvin who's the head
of the UN Foundation which has been very
involved in this issue beside her Larry
Cox who is the head of Amnesty
International the executive director of
amnesty which has likewise been involved
in this as a as a central human rights
issue and an veneman the director
executive director of UNICEF which has
both gathered the data on this the three
million figure annually in Africa alone
figure that the Julia cited and has also
been very active in supporting one of
the ventures in Senegal toast and that
has been most effective in in releasing
progress against this Cathy let me maybe
start with you you know is indeed one of
the problems that this does feel like a
taboo topic that you know it always
seems to me that a so many more millions
people died of AIDS because of involved
sex and it was hard to talk about is the
problem here that it involves genitals
and so it's something that it's very
hard to have a serious conversation
about you know I actually think it's not
a hard subject to have a conversation
about and that joy has said the right
thing I don't think people really
understand that it still exists it's
sort of as one of those things that we
heard about in our childhood and we
don't hear enough about it today so I my
hat is off to Julia for bringing this
back up front and center I think the
other reason we don't hear as much about
it is it's about girls and we don't
really have an understanding of the life
of 600 million girls around the world
that they don't get to stay in school
they get married off early they're
subject to genital mutilation their
lives are challenging in ways that
American girls don't really understand
and when they hear about it they're
shocked they think it's unfair and they
want to do something so yes there's
probably something about ooh now how do
we talk about this I frankly think
reproductive health is just as difficult
to talk about especially when it comes
to girls but increasingly people I heard
Melinda Gates yesterday speaking out
about it it's time to deal with these
issues and so here we are Larry one I
had a conversation
once with a Sudanese daya woman who does
the cutting and I pushed her on general
cutting and she said this is our culture
this is our religion what businesses of
you Americans whether we circumcise our
daughters how do we how do we answer her
well it's a very important question and
when amnesty started working on this
several decades ago it was a question
that actually for a while even divided
our own our own membership people were
very afraid that they were being
culturally insensitive or even
imperialistic in taking this on I think
what makes the difference is hearing the
voices of the actual women who
experience this and who are fighting
against it now then becomes clear it's
not a question who defines the culture
and how does culture change culture is
not something stagnant of course it's
easy for us to say you know Human Rights
always trump culture it's also
interesting that these cultural
arguments are usually are not always
used to justify cruelty and pain that
affect women and not men i think if men
were being cut in this way somehow the
cultural arguments would fade away but i
think it is very important to a listen
to to the to the women themselves make
their voices heard because that
completely undercuts the argument that
this is something being imposed from
abroad it's not and secondly i think it
is important to take the cultural
argument seriously in the sense that to
end the practice one has to really
seriously address how you get the whole
community to understand that this is
something which is not in the interests
of the community not in the interest of
the girls they care about and to take
the lead in fact in trying to stop it
let me and let me sort of follow up on
that in a sense that this is something
that the West has pushed hard against
really since the 1920s I think because
of British influence Sudan band
infibulation which is the worst kind of
FGM back in 1925 and similar period in
Kenya and in fact it really led in those
especially those early periods just
something of a back
and there was this sense of these
outside Imperial is telling us what to
do this is our culture so and if you
could maybe talk a little bit about I
mean is it fair to say that especially
since the 1970s when there was a
ramped-up effort that that effort really
didn't that it really was something of a
failure I mean that which is my view but
that now in the last ten years or so
we're kind of getting the formula for
what works I think part of the problem
is as you say that people react to
having them having them their cultures
you know said that they're they're not
right so as Nick mentioned one of the
organizations that has been very
successful is an organization called
toast and tio sdan for those of you who
want to look it up on the web it worked
primarily in West Africa but also across
the band of Africa where this practice
is most prevalent but I think the
important thing about it is is that it
starts at the community level with
community discussions one of the first
things that they did was they no longer
refer to it as female genital mutilation
because the word mutilation is
judgmental the word cutting is factual
this came about with conversations with
the leadership of the communities
themselves i visited the first community
that toast n began in and they started
by talking with the imam the senior
leader this was a community where men in
women were so separated that the women
literally had to walk in a different
part of the whole community if the men
were sitting in the town square there
was absolutely no mixing of men and
women so they began with the imam to
talk about the health impacts and
suddenly the lights go on and say well
yes i remember my niece went a little
crazy after this because of infection
well they had never put the health
impacts really on the agenda
so then they begin to talk about it as a
human rights issue the community now has
come together men and women not only has
this practice they've abandoned it as a
community but they've also seen that the
education rates have gone up the access
to health care has gone up better access
for women to reproductive health
services and attend a burst so there's
been a lot of impacts of working
together as a community now the other
thing that they found again a cultural
aspect is you couldn't just do it in one
community and so you had to reach out to
the other communities because the
question was if my daughter is not cut
she won't be able to get married because
it's a cultural expectation and so they
had to begin to work in groups of
communities to really get impact on this
practice now there are over 4,000
communities now in Senegal that have
abandoned as a result of this
community-based approach and so I think
we now know what the formula is that
works and just to push a little harder I
mean is it fair to say that the previous
campaign really since the 1970s these
laws past conferences held I was in
Guinea last year where FGM is punishable
by life imprisonment on the part of the
parents or in some cases if the girl
dies actually by execution and yet
ninety-nine percent of Ghanaian girls
are still cut I mean given the need to
learn from mistakes is it fair to say
that that long campaign until the more
community-based approach or toast and
really is a failure that we should learn
from and I'll toss that out to anybody
whether I don't mean that subject and to
do this but you're welcome to address
that an or anybody else can I think I
mean I think this is this is one of the
consequences is that you know people
don't want to be told what to do
particularly when they believe it's part
of their culture that's that has been
around for generations on the other hand
one of
the countries with the highest
prevalence of female genital cutting is
Egypt and they have particularly with
some of the women in the country
speaking out themselves some of the
local women some of the leaders
including the first lady speaking out on
these issues they're finding that they
can have an impact particularly as more
and more women get access or more and
more families get access to television
so they can address some of these issues
on things like soap operas or other ways
of communicating with women on
television to begin a little bit more
dialogue about whether or not this is
really something that has to be
continued in the culture or whether or
not it can be changed I think as well
that the absolute importance of a
multi-level approach so the community
grassroots level work is absolutely
vital but unless as you say the
legislation is there unless legislation
is enforced unless there's allied
advocacy and media campaigns coming in
to tell people about the changes in law
recently Uganda outlawed FGM but there's
criticism there that governments done
very little to actually tell people with
in Uganda that it's illegal so you you
need an approach across the board that
is there to reinforce this message and
Julia there's a question here that from
a youtube viewer and I wondered if you
could answer it while raising some of
the the consequences of Jeff the
practical consequences in terms of
health sexuality whatever it may be that
Mitch from London says if you could
spend five minutes with the grandmother
of a girl that was about to be cut
presumably the grandmother being
assumption is grandmother's maker there
if you could spend five minutes with a
grandmother of girl it was about to be
cut what would you say you know the
first thing I would do actually if maybe
let's pretend Mitch didn't say five
minutes let's okay um okay not five
minutes um actually first of all I'd
listen I'm volunteering in this area and
I
no as Larry was talking about this
charge of cultural imperialism coming in
changing communities I cannot sit in
front of a grandmother and leap in and
tell her why this is wrong but what i
can do is talk about health impacts as
an said the causal links between what
happens in FGM and then the constant
infections the SEP says the childbirth
complications everything that results
are not known often because the Gaza cut
at such a young age so they don't
realize that the impacts that this has
and in fact many circumcised a--'s are
the greatest advocates within their own
community to say why this must end once
they've seen it Larry you're you and
your organization are obviously focused
on human rights and if a what has the
human rights community been sort of slow
to look to focus on some of these broad
issues that involve every home in other
words if a Sudanese dissident gets
arrested by the government then
obviously everybody writes letters if
three million girls a year get cut then
you know whether it's organizations
whether it's we in the media that people
kind of tuned out yeah there's no doubt
about we have been too slow and it's a
sort of painful history to have to look
at to understand not only points of this
issue but the important general of the
rights of women as key not only to women
but to in fact the advancement of all
human rights and it really was the
women's movement that pushed the human
rights community to begin to understand
this and as it did our work on all human
rights began to improve because the
lessons that you've learned about
FGM are lessons that in fact apply to
other human rights violations as well
that you have to work with the community
that you have to understand you have to
listen that you have to empower the
people who are there and you also
understand that in this issue it's not
simply a question of this issue separate
from the larger issue of violence
against women and the larger issue of
the devaluation of women of the
discrimination against women I don't
think you can really solve and toast and
certainly took this approach the reason
it adopted a human rights approach was
because human rights speak across the
board that has it's a holistic vision of
what people need is not just issue
oriented but it's issued on what the
basic rights that everyone needs and
when it did that the community began to
understand this not as an isolated
cultural practice than everyone
condemned but as part of a general fight
for for the human rights of everybody in
the community and I think that made a
difference but we have we we have
learned a lot and we need to keep
learning I think now I'm proud to say
that certainly my own organization has
made the rights of women central Central
to to its work on human rights and I
would just add you know where the UN is
on the ground dealing with this weather
it's UNICEF or UNFPA the population
funder unifem the approach is actually a
very holistic one where they're trying
to keep the girls in school and take
care of all the other issues that change
both the culture of the community and
the girls own aspirations for her life
and is in effect empowering her but the
cutting takes place at such an early age
you you have to deal with them the
mothers and the father's and the whole
community so the girl doesn't become an
advocate for herself until it's too late
I find it interesting that you know
there's roughly 28 countries in which
it's prevalent still 19 of them have
laws against it it is criminal
criminalized in those countries but
that's only half and even in those
countries we're still fighting this
battle so there is a rule of law problem
here that I'm sure you're dealing with
as well that it that's not the only
answer obviously it you need you need
these groups in there trying to change
the culture at the bar and it's also
it's it's not a problem is just confined
to Africa or I mean it's now around the
world it's in Europe it's in the United
States and that even makes it even more
complicated to talk about how you're
going to to stop it well actually that
goes to a question here Rob from lose
which i think is in the UK asks you and
others have talked about the need to
stop FGM within a generation do you
really think you can do it Kathy well
there's a goal that the UN is set to
eliminate it by 2015 which is the date
for the Millennium Development Goals I
don't think there's any reason we
shouldn't be trying for that that's
that's far enough away that we could
really do a concerted effort and frankly
it's going to take a global campaign you
know we need a global campaign for girls
this ought to be right front and center
at the beginning of it so I think it's
doable there's a there may be a parallel
with China foot-binding was actually
punishable by exile on the part of the
parents at zero effect I mean it various
points was banned no impact and then
early in the 20th century really
remarkably quickly it disappeared and it
went from a perception on the part of
parents that if they didn't bind their
daughters Feith it'd be hard for her to
marry to a perception that if they bound
her feet it'd be harder for her to get
married and it you know I guess the
question is yeah one Emperor changed the
rule it was really a bottom-up social
movement it led by led by elites from
within the country part of this sense of
Awakening and supported by outsiders for
some degree but but really led from
within push from within so I guess the
you know the question is how we can
replicate that and whether groups like
host an are indeed whether this is the
next sort of foot-binding analogy so
that the change once it comes you which
tipping point happens very very quickly
III just want to come back to that point
Kathy made at 2015 um I wish I shared
your optimism
the I just feel that we're here talking
about solutions we seem to know what
works we know this model is there we
know about the respect we have to give
to communities and many many local NGOs
and civil society organizations are
working on the ground and you know to
pay tribute to all of those small
organizations really at danger as well
one of the women who's contacted me
through this campaign Lucy Masha who
said you know go forth and speak at
Davos about this and her story once she
started speaking out within her
community she was raped she was beaten
she was tied to a tree she was jailed
she's luckily living now in the US but I
think what we need to see is how we can
in the next five years if that is true
take this to scale I'm using the
language of Davos there but really you
know what is preventing us if we know
how to make things change um why can't
we put this into place is it a funding
issue is it a global awareness issue
what needs to happen what are the levers
that we can pull if we were here sitting
here saying actually this is to
intractable this is too difficult we're
not going to address this issue fair
enough but we're all sitting here in
Vermont agreement that this is a severe
human rights abuses a child rights abuse
or women's rights abuse we've got a
solution what can we do a bunch of
people from on YouTube asked variations
of that that what you know what have we
learned from from well one person has
what we can learn from HIV campaigns
that can be transposed into working to
eradicate FGM various other people ask
you know variations of that but and
given what you talked about earlier
isn't indeed one lesson perhaps that a
bunch of outsiders at the treetops the
top-down efforts on their own aren't
going to get very far and that what does
work is
is outsider is supporting indigenous
efforts within the culture and giving
them the microphone and and a standing
back and letting them lead the way I
mean is that is that part of it well I
absolutely think it's part of it I think
that if you can't change the norms the
practices of communities unless you
listen and understand and have a
dialogue and again the toast down
approach did exactly that listen to the
y listen to the perceptions and then
also gave information about the health
effects the facts I think that's one of
the things that we haven't done enough
of as an international community around
a number of these issues and you
mentioned hiv/aids you know one of the
most difficult things we've gotten
better coverage of prevention of
mother-to-child transmission of
treatment of AIDS generally of treatment
of pediatric AIDS one of the most
difficult things has been to understand
really how to have an impact with
education it just hasn't seemed to work
and part of it is I don't think we
understand and listen to communities
enough for example you know one of the
things that you talk about in the
southern africa where aids is most
prevalent is use of condoms but there
are practices in places like Swaziland
we're in order to get married you have
to get pregnant first to show your
fertility well it's a little difficult
to talk about using condoms when you
want to get pregnant and so I think if
you don't listen to the community and
understand the whys the how the
practices work and what's going on truly
in the communities and have a dialogue
about it you can't actually make the
change and i think this this human
rights approach engaging the community
and human rights in women's rights in
men and women understanding each other
and why things are happening is a way to
really make
act in changing some of these practices
particularly those that are most harmful
for women Larry if I could just you know
because I don't want to create a sort of
dichotomy between the approach that you
just described which I fully support and
the idea of outside pressure because
that can lead to a kind of paralysis on
the part of people who aren't able to
have a dialogue with the community and I
think the lesson not only on this issue
but on many many other issues is as
Julia said you need a multi-level or
multi-faceted kind of approach because I
think to take your China example which
is really fascinating which I want to
like learn to use more there was also
very very strong political will on the
part of the government that played a
major role i think as i understand it at
least i'm thinking about you know i am
Zhang I think it previous points there
was a central political will that
actually didn't really get anywhere and
at the time when foot-binding really
ended up being eradicated you had very
weak central government's that I was
thinking that was relieved with after
the revolution but your gate before well
it began happening before in the end of
the Ching dynasty and then and then
after that in a period when you had real
social awakening but pretty fragile
central government's well anyway my
point is that I think you need to put we
need to put pressure on governments to
not simply pass laws which is the easy
thing to do but to actually not in not
allow the kinds of practices that Julia
talked about I mean it's you know where
people are being threatened people our
lives are in danger you need the outside
world needs to be in support in a very
practical way of people who are speaking
out and who are being threatened as a
result of being speaking out on on this
issue as well as on other women's rights
issue so I I don't think it's an
either/or thing I think that we need
very much to correct what I think is a
long-standing failure to appreciate the
community approach but i also think we
still
need to keep in general let me press you
one had a little further since you have
a y-chromosome here and i think they're
be you know some men watching whether
here or on youtube who will think hey
you know this isn't my fight I don't
have a clitoris and what and and the
same thing I think applies to a lot of
other women's rights issues what do you
say to them is this their fight or not
oh it absolutely is their fight if they
care at all about you know human rights
about their own freedom and their own
dignity i mean i think that that that
was my point about the linkage between
the fight for women's rights and the
fight for all of human rights i mean
it's not we all can very easily draw the
draw the connections between the status
of women in any particular society and
the general status of human rights in
that society and that includes the
societies in which many of the people
who are watching this this discussion
live in so far as and in its the
experience of my own my own life and my
own my own organization that it was the
struggle of women for their rights that
made us understand our own our own
rights and the way things are connected
and and the way that the approach we
were taking was a very narrow and very
limited approach so i think it's it's in
the vital interest of every man and we
of course don't live in isolation from
women you know we have daughters we have
wives we have lovers we you know it's
inconceivable to me that someone could
say this is not of any interest to me
because I'm a male and this happens to
women any more than I would expect women
to say I'm not really interested in what
happened to Nelson Mandela because he
was a man and I'm a woman I mean what
kind of world is that where we suddenly
divide our feelings about maybe one way
thinking of it is that the Holocaust
attend today wasn't a Jewish you civil
rights where the black issue and FGM
isn't just a women's issue except for
and I think particularly met men pay
such a huge part in the communities that
practice this as Ana's said because one
of the key reasons for FGM being in
place is it makes a girl murrah jable
and when as part of these community
conversations the men come together and
decide that they will marry an uncut
woman this is how it changes within a
generation and you then move to the next
community which is the intra Marian
group so men are so vital in this debate
and particularly as religious leaders as
well and I think when we focus on rights
we get stuck when we focus on economics
which is really what this all comes down
to is kind of what's a girl worth and is
this about marrying her for her value it
changes I think because it's girls
people do react differently than women
so I think that's going to help bring
more people to the issue we've used
economic incentives in a number of cases
to get communities to think differently
about early marriage and the consequence
of the man finally having a reason to
stop and think about his daughter
marrying early or marrying late when
there's an economic incentive to do so
and in the case in Ethiopia a girl who
stays in school is eligible for a sheep
or a goat for her family if she stays in
school two more years the father's have
been saying hmm I wasn't really in the
conversation before I had no reason to
have the conversation I no reason to
think about it and the reason to think
about the value my daughter could bring
to my family if she stayed in school
longer the economic incentive got him to
pay attention so I I'm for the hybrid
solution which is the community Lee
listening incentives where where we can
or we can apply them and I know not
everybody loves incentives but I think
they do work and and the external
pressure but I think right sometimes
gets people into a different kind of
conversation where they they have a
different view right thinking of a
different kind of conversation now we've
been I mean we've been discussing sit at
one level but I want to kind of make it
real and we have a video clip from Molly
and I have not yet seen it I'm
brief that everybody in the history of
the world who's ever seen it has
promptly burst into tears afterward and
so pull out your handkerchiefs but if we
can roll that video that'd be great
hey Lenny Leoni can if you order from
Miami City
I hey I get you to manually add drama
the motto
well that goes on a zillion times a day
in in much of the world and I don't know
exactly what kind of cutting this was
but it did not appear to be infibulation
which is the much worse kind and in that
case the girl's legs are afterward often
tied together and for a couple of weeks
or so so the woman can heal and is you
know is that squared Jennifer I'm sorry
Jane from the UK asks how can women
fight GM in cultures where they have no
voice and likewise am from devin says
FGM seems to be about what women in some
cultures believe they must do and be to
have value to the men who hold power if
we're to change the thinking of men and
women in these cultures what can we draw
on from our own experience to guide us
and let me put out this frame that to
the panel I mean I think there's a
perception that this is often really
about men oppressing women and it seems
to me at least that it's much more
complicated than that and that typically
this is what women in fact are doing to
other women that the men they may want
to marry a girl is cut but they're
largely removed from the decision-making
and in fact partly because men are more
likely to be educated they seems quite
plausible to me that that men are
more likely to be against FGM than women
are in these countries I don't know any
survey but that anecdotally I wouldn't
be surprised if that's the case so I
wonder if the problem you know isn't
often patriarchal values even
misogynistic values that are absorbed
and transmitted as much by women as by
men you know if that isn't a better way
of looking at this then men oppressing
women well and the video just showed
women are the primary carriers of the
culture I mean an you you've probably
because you've seen it you know that
that's that is the way it's passed on
you may have a point of view on that but
that's how it it is carried in the
community well I think that I mean
certainly that clip showed that it is
practiced when it's actually done it's
it's women who cut the girls and but yet
it is the men who were saying my
daughter will not be able to get married
if she's not cut so i think it's it's a
practice it's a culture that has to be
addressed as a whole not it's not just
women it's not just men it's everybody's
responsibility to kind of look at how
this is going to change now having said
that it is not the same it's not
practiced the same in every country i
went a year before last to sierra leone
who's reading my briefing papers and i
find out female genital cutting is quite
prevalent in sierra leone so I call up
Mally mal chin who founded toast n and I
said what are you doing in Sierra Leone
she said we're not because it's
completely different they practice
something called secret societies and
secret societies are where girls would
go before there was an education system
they would go off for maybe a few months
at a time and they would learn how to be
a wife they learn how to all of these
different things this was their
education
and part of it was they got cut now
those secret societies still exist in
Sierra Leone and still a number of young
girls get cut although less and less and
the secret societies are much less about
going for a long period of time and more
just about cutting now but one of the
things i found when i was there is that
young teenage girls who were still in
school we're talking about these secret
societies and these practices as things
that they were going to try to help be a
part of the past and so i think there is
some ability to engage in some of these
kinds of communities again the practices
are different and in that country it's
it's done in a completely different way
so i think again it's about listening
it's about learning learning about the
particular culture and practices of a
country and the history of it i think is
key to finding the way to eliminate it
speaking of culture and practices i mean
one other layer of complexity here is
frankly religion that there and i want
to be very clear here a great part of
the muslim world does not practice
cutting there's nothing in the Quran
about cutting in the Arabian Peninsula
almost nobody does any cutting and there
are also a number of Christian places
Ethiopian particular that in fact in
Ethiopia Christians do some of the most
severe cutting all that said I most of
the cutting occurs in Muslim countries
whether that is in Africa or in Asia and
doesn't that I'm given the problems
right now between the west and the
Muslim world doesn't that create one
more layer of complexity if you have
Western efforts to go against practice
that is disproportionately embedded in
the Muslim world and I don't know who I
want a hand this night this potato do
but
no pass it on can I live can I dead turn
it around and just say mauritania has
just issued a fatwa against FGM 34
Islamic leaders have actually just said
that this is as you say absolutely not
in the Quran and and not an issue I hate
to address the positives in the debate
but some you know that there is changing
and at least if we know that this is one
of the key issues at least we can begin
to address it yeah I think one of the
things that's changed also that we we
need to not keep acting as if it hasn't
changed is that you know human rights
issues at least are no longer a concern
of the West somehow the human rights
movement is no longer located in the
West it's everywhere there are human
rights organizations there are thousands
of human rights organizations in
virtually every region and in the Muslim
world there are incredible organizations
and fighters for human rights and I
think what has to shift is that we need
to see it this is something my
organization has to struggle with is how
do we shift our role from being sort of
you know the saviors of the world that
Savior paradigm to a role of like really
empowering and trying to help and listen
to those organizations in those cultures
or finally there is an incredible
struggle which we often don't publicize
very much we don't write about it very
much we act as if it's not there within
Islam within the Muslim world on these
issues on what it means and that's the
struggle I think which is ultimately
going to determine the success for the
reasons we gave about when human rights
succeed it's because they're rooted in
the indigenous struggle in in the
culture and that's what I think is the
hope for this that it's a becoming a
global issue not a Western issue being
imposed on the part of the world that
carries it out which was the model
decades ago Marian from Germany asks
what do you think should be the
punishment levied by the international
community for nations that permit FGM
now I don't I my hunch is that probably
none of you think that countries as such
should be punished but why not what we
mean our
there are levers that we can apply to
countries to take this issue more
seriously or would that create a
backlash that would be unhelpful it's
already there in the maputo protocol
which has been signed up to by many
african states but not yet ratified so
absolute we have a role to play as an
international community to get some of
these issues and shrine din law and you
know we had a conversation about seed or
the elimination of this Justin sorry the
commission of the elimination against
discrimination against women trips off
the tongue you know and all of these
levers do play an important part I think
and we need to keep the pressure up to
ensure that their ratified seed always
been of course passed by I don't know
100 and I don't know how many countries
and one of the very few that has not
passed it is the US let me open this up
more broadly I there folks here we have
a microphone hi I'm Michelle from San
Francisco and I my phone I'm one of the
many volunteers of the v-day and i'm
also a doctoral program and
international human rights education in
san francisco so i wrote a paper last
year on FGM and in the literature i
noticed that um one of the reasons why
the women are continuing the cutting is
because it's one of its their means of
economic sustainability so I was
wondering given then it's the Economic
Forum what public private sector
partnerships have been built in if there
any subsidy subsidies that governments
might be giving two women to help them
transition from this profession and what
means are in what else we can do a civil
civil society actors to help move that
forward and also in terms of leveraging
some of the new media technologies like
kiva.org and women for women
international and donors choose like
what we can do to help move that forward
you know I we've been trying to move the
issue of girls actually up on the agenda
of Davos and have had been fairly
successful had a very good session
yesterday about girls and trying to look
at the actors government nonprofits in
business and there's a role for each
we've actually just created a girl fund
to help support with private sector
money as well as government money work
in communities to give
girls more rights keep them in school
give them access to health and freedom
from these from sexual violence or some
of these other causes so I think
increasingly if we get more players who
are educated about this and are engaged
in it the money does talk and in you
know that will be an important piece of
changing the way the culture works and I
mean to what Julia said earlier I think
the communities need to see that this is
part and parcel of what it will take for
them to grow and to become a modern
modern area so I absolutely think you're
right that we've we've got to make this
a part of the work that all of the
communities are doing so when the u.s.
puts money into these communities this
is one of the things they're checking
for I would just say also add that in
not in Senegal but in most other places
the person who does the cutting is that
is the traditional birth attendant the
traditional Midwife and wanna there has
to be a much broader effort to address
maternal health I mean there's this it's
a scandal that more than half million
women die a year in childbirth
unnecessarily and partly that is because
there has been a broad and essentially
failed effort to improve maternal health
through traditional birth attendants
that did not work and now I think we're
all realizing that but as we gear up a
newer system to improve maternal health
based on people who actually have much
better training you can refer to
hospitals who bring people to clinics
real midwives then I think it's
plausible that those people will then
have influence in those communities over
reproductive health and it will go away
from these traditional these diet who
are the ones who were doing the cutting
you know what sorry what I find quite
shocking about the FGM arena is the fact
that a hundred and forty million women
are living with the consequence of FGM
and they appear to be missing from
things like the maternal mortality
debate from the the child death all of
the MDGs that they
addresses and the continuum of care that
is needed for these women in particular
and yet there's so much happening within
this field and everywhere I look FGM
always seems to be missing and I think
exactly as you say all of these
instruments can come into play and in a
way what we need to do is to be focusing
on a plethora of solutions that can help
bring this back into the mainstream
really if I might just pick up on on the
whole issue of maternal health and these
issues you know we had a little film
about Molly and the prevalence of female
genital cutting in Mali but in many of
these countries there's also a very high
incidence along with female genital
cutting of early marriage and the two
issues combined we know that the the
risks to maternal health are greater
with women who have been cut we also
know that a that a girl who was under
the age of 15 who gives birth is five
has a five times greater chance of dying
in childbirth and so when I was molly
was my last field trip as a matter of
fact just in November and I had very
interesting conversations with the
Health Minister about his responsibility
to address the issues of early marriage
and female genital cutting because they
truly are issues with health
consequences to women and affect the
maternal health and mortality issues I
mean Kathy let me just follow up on that
given the success of this grassroots
kind of toast and model of Education
discussion leading to addressing FGM can
that same model then be applied to the
whole planet play of other issues of
getting keeping girls from dropping out
of school preventing child marriage of
various reproductive health questions
including a family planning I mean is is
this bottom-up grassroots supporting
local actors model is that something
that can be used again
a whole variety of other threats to the
well-being of girls around the world I
mean I think that's the only way it can
happen I think when we've tried to do
things like let's just focus on
education or just focus on health we're
not nearly successful because we're not
dealing with the underlying issue of the
girls value so if you put them all
together economic empowerment education
health especially access to this kind of
health care and reproductive rights then
you're really dealing with a whole
change mechanism that can make a big
difference but it it really has to be
that and luckily the UN has a five-point
approach to girls and that's the way
they do it and I think increasingly we
will all adopt that kind of a holistic
to your word holistic approach Ron
Freeman troika dialog muskie madame la
la maharaj mentioned in mauritania
collective fatwa against FGM I wonder if
we could get a few more facts about what
led to that and whether it has any
mileage so to speak I do know that there
has been a real effort by some the
community organizers to get Muslim
clerics organized in this effort because
there is a perception on the part of
many ordinary people that this is
religious that this is their religion
and so when you get mm saying now now
they don't do this in Saudi Arabia they
does nothing in the Quran that that then
that actually has a tremendous amount of
authority and so I that it has been one
reason for trying to get these these
always SAT was for a young global leader
and actually I come from the Muslim
world and this is why I wanted kind of
to interfere and give the comment in
fact something like this is totally
prohibited in the Muslim world and just
kind of to rephrase kristef question I
would assume it's more culturally than
its religiously so this is more actually
instead of saying that it's Islam so
that's kind of the first layer to really
acknowledge it and I really respect them
to any venom man by mentioning that the
first lady in Egypt stood out and
acknowledge that this is totally against
our let's say or there
traditions their religion and alder
let's see the social intrinsic values
that we were raised up through now
unfortunately it's mama my own analysis
it's only a comment a comment so allow
me to take some time please well it when
just one direction no there's no
question just wanted to clarify that so
thank you thank you i'm jim breyer i'm a
venture capitalist with axial partners
in palo alto and i've been on the board
of facebook an investor in facebook for
about five years ah what's your next
investment well we we have about a dozen
investments in social media companies
around the world and Julia and for any
other panels that might be interested
what can we as either business investors
are part of the business community
around social media do better to further
many of these causes that we've talked
about today I'm going to talk to you
afterwards one-on-one because I need
your advice I mean absolutely i was i
was talking with someone just the other
day about how he uses mobile phones to
get medicines into villages and able to
predict supply and demand and in a much
much clearer way and having been out in
Africa knowing that the growing use of
that sort of technology is absolutely
crucial I mean imagine if this network
as we said before taking things to scale
imagine if we can do that through
empowering community leaders to you know
even if it's someone saying I know that
there's a cutting ceremony that's due to
take place within two months and then
being able to gear up around that I
think there's so much that can be done
and and the empowerment around that is
huge but also what I found through my
experience is how many people have
contacted me globally so this is not
just about what the West can do I had so
many emails from people in cameroon in
Guinea in all sorts of places saying
what can I do in my own community and
one thought is just about you know
there's not
one database for example that's someone
contacted me from guinea-bissau to say
can i download from the web i'm about to
teach this class what can i download
from the web i couldn't find a single
place where that person could just go to
be able to say to their community these
are the issues that you could deal with
so we need to hit this straight on let
me get something there visibly what
julia has done I mean that frankly one
of the problems is that we in the news
media tend to drop the ball on these
kinds of issues that what we do is we
tend to cover what happened yesterday we
tend not to cover what happens every day
and whether it's public health issues
whether it's this kind of daily human
rights abuse it just falls through the
cracks and since we don't since we in
the media tend to be the ones who helped
shape the agenda and since we drop the
bowl on these kinds of issues that
leaves it frankly to people like Julia
to bring it up on the agenda and I
really salute you for having done that
at Davos and I think that that is a
model for the whole range of other
issues whether it's malaria or I mean
that anything else that you know this is
our greatest weakness we are not good at
covering things that happen every day we
blow it on those issues and you've got
to raise those and pocus and kind of
hold her feet to the fire so that we
actually do a better job of covering
these incredibly important issues that
are ongoing in part of the backdrop and
get ignored as a result if I might just
talk talk a little bit about you talked
about the use of cell phones for
everything from monitoring nutrition to
health and UNICEF's doing a lot of this
work but we also support toast an
extensively and one of the ideas of
toast and has been that these
communities that have become toast and
communities eliminating the practice
through this community-based approach
suddenly they begin to see cell phones
in these communities particularly owned
by women and yet most of the women are
illiterate so they've now started in
some of the toast and communities
a texting for literacy program where
they're teaching women how to read
because it's so much cheaper to text
than talk in Africa unlike the US and so
I would challenge the tech community to
say how do we take the next leap forward
recognizing that many of these
communities that practice these cultures
are now in to the cell community as well
yeah my name is Richard I run an
international NGO that works on Aging in
the developing world and firstly I opted
my NGO and our partners over 70
countries to play a role older people in
many of the countries are connected to
this particular practice and maybe we
can actually do something constructive
and maybe a coalition needs to be built
but I think one of the most striking
things for me is about voice I mean it
is important i can't remember the name
of the somali model that wrote her
autobiography about her life but i think
the more that that happens the more that
voice can be heard at the national level
and actually women who have had to bear
this are able to have the courage to
speak and using facebook you know that
maybe there are ways to enable voice to
be heard I think that that will be
transformational and I don't know quite
how we do that but so maybe a useful
strategy hello I'm from Switzerland
Isabel and I just wanted to ask what
kind of programs do we have to empower
mothers who have been cut they say they
need to do it for the daughters but how
can we empower them to educate their
sons not to marry a cut girl because
then if the expectation is not there
anymore maybe the girls won't undergo
this part of the model that we're all
saying tossed and you know in fact a
number of local civil society
organizations are also implementing this
model part of that is that as well as
having conversations with the women you
of course have conversations with the
men and of course mothers are talking
with their sons
as part of this but the whole community
is coming together so the hope is is
that that everyone all at once does come
to a shift in awareness about the
practice Thank You Mina Al Arabia I work
with a shuttlepod of newspaper and I'm
also a young global leader just wanted
to ask you in terms of getting
spokespeople from communities that have
given up female genital mutilation to go
to communities that haven't yet i mean
i'm sure you've had some experience with
this but if we can take that to a
greater scale if there's funding for
such project to facilitate their travel
because i think that's the best way to
get the message out to say that we used
to do it and we've given up and these
are the benefits is probably the best
person with credibility cuz often with
these issues it's about credibility and
i think it's wonderful have you raised
that this is not an issue for muslims or
that islam is the one calling for this
and I think that breaks away the taboo
because if you tell Muslims and I am one
of them that this is not to say that
just because you're a Muslim we think
that you're a bad person doing this on
the contrary there is an appreciation
that this is not something that the
Quran dick takes but sadly there are
those that took the religion on so many
different levels so I salute the way
you've approached it I know that when
people you know have been making this
point the fact that Saudi Arabia does
not that there's no that there is not
cutting inside of you that is one of the
things that is always emphasized and one
of the things that has the greatest you
know this price of people has the
greatest authority I don't know of any
case doesn't if anybody else has of you
know people envoy's being sent clerics
from Saudi Arabia for example to
communities in these countries to say
you know you've got it wrong but I mean
in fact they're in my experience
invariably in every country there are
voices from within that country who are
saying this is ridiculous this is not
and and so I know in to the extent those
people speak the language and have local
credibility and authority sorry very
very quickly but just I mean the
communities that did use to practice it
that's what I mean like you mentioned in
Senegal or mauritania where there's a
committee that it was I mean Reese
Lee actually practice and then given up
because I think that's the most credible
voice no very good point I want to now
kind of wind up and for those who didn't
get a chance to ask your questions you
know feel free to mob the folks here
afterward and but you know we've been
talking about it happens three million
girls a year human rights violation I
think we agree on a vast scale leads to
more maternal mortality leads to more
girls dying of infection at a scale week
and we don't really know when a girl
dies after she's been cut people just
say oh she died of malaria it's it's
people don't acknowledge how often this
happens but what do we do somebody is
here wants to get involved somebody's
watching on YouTube they can go to the
toast n website which is toast an org
tio sta n org I learn more about it in
that way they can go to Julia's website
and oh oh I don't know and FGM now org
but also another excellent website is
forward UK org UK which is where I
volunteer as for you so let's go
systematically through here maybe Kathy
if you can start and you know what what
does somebody do yeah well i think it's
it's awesome that this that the youtube
community chose this issue and already
has stood up for it so having a voice is
the first thing the second is to become
an advocate for girls if you haven't
seen the girl effect video which is on
youtube its it's an awesome thing and i
think it gives you the sense of the
positive that if you can become an
advocate for girls we can end some of
these troublesome things i think you had
a great idea which is instead of shame
and blame we ought to be finding those
who've already begun to fight back and
you know we all probably need to do a
better job of thanking Uganda for just
making the the thing against the law
right now so I think we all have voices
and we should be using them more and
we've got the tools now well first of
all I think it's clear to everybody that
this is part of a larger struggle for
for women's rights in general and and I
think and I'm happy to be agreed with
Nick on this that this is a particular
moment in history where this battle
really is ripe can really be there can
be a sea change in the world I think FGM
is part of that issue I think I'll think
it's the only one but it's a continuum
of how we raise the status of women and
how we just make intolerable practices
that have seemed tolerable so that's the
first thing and there's myriad ways for
people to get involved and it's not only
a question of the West against the
developing world it's also a question of
the fight within each country where
these issues are still involved so I
think that's the first thing and the
second thing is that amnesty is involved
right now in a campaign in Europe to try
to change the practices and policies of
the European Union to make sure that
they're supporting the kind of
approaches that we've talked about here
it's very easy for people to get
involved in that they can google their
or their local amnesty website from
whatever country they're in and also to
make sure that that women who are trying
to to get refuge in this country are in
countries in Europe because they have a
legitimate fear of being forced to be
cut that the laws are changed to make
that possible for them to do and Julia
in case anybody doesn't have your
website down yet clearly the website but
I what I really think we need to do is
make FGM much more explicit the data the
paucity of the data is shocking there is
a lot that's out there but how can we
ascertain the global scale of this issue
if we don't actually know what we're
dealing with the three million figure
we're all quoting is in Africa alone it
doesn't tackle Indonesia Yemen UAE it
doesn't tackle Europe where we know
500,000 women are living with FGM so we
don't understand the scale we don't
understand what needs to be done on a
country-by-country basis to tackle the
problem a solution in Indonesia is
completely different to what we need in
cameroon in Sierra Leone as Anna said as
in Senegal we need to be very very
cognizant of what is the global action
plan without that we can't cost a
solution if this is a matter of
resources than great let's just get on
and fundraise but until we are much more
aware about the global scale of this
problem and what needs to be done about
it we can't reach that target of 2015 I
think very kind offer from an NGO
already working in this field thank you
I'll be in touch and but equally all the
NGOs working in this area please get FGM
on your agenda do something more about
it and I've run out of steam go to my
website there are five easy things that
you can do there they may seem little
things and but lastly do what you can
this is going out to the YouTube
community there'll be people watching
all over the world I chose to enter a
competition on Davos you may want to
find out what is happening in your local
community you may wish to fundraise you
may wish to push your government on
various things or your MP know what your
action is and what your agency is and
please just do something its
international FGM day sorry
international anti FGM day on the sixth
of februari that's a week today contact
a journalist talk about FGM thank you
don't feel free to contact me don't feel
you have to contact this journalist in
particular I'm already on board an well
I certainly I would agree with all
that's been said um but I think its
first of all so important to recognize
that this is first and foremost a
violation of the rights of the girl
child think about the fact that most of
the people the children who are
subjected to this are between about the
ages of four and maybe 12 I mean this is
a human being that really doesn't have
the right to say no it's a
posed on her the second thing I would
say is that everyone should look at
those organizations that are working in
this arena it isn't a popular cause
these organizations can't generate lots
of resources for their work and so
support those organizations that are
truly making a difference in this area
um let me just also say finally that you
know this is indeed just part of a
broader puzzle and and that quite aside
from the simple moral issue it's an
eminently practical issue we're not
going to make progress against global
poverty against insecurity unless girls
are brought into the picture brought
into the formal economy educated and so
on this is one facet of that larger
picture and then we really hope that you
whether you're here right here or
watching on YouTube will get engaged and
I think Julia really deserves our thanks
and appreciation for bringing this issue
to Davos and to YouTube to the Davos
debate and please join me in thanking
her and all the panelists here today
you